from the other business of the council
first we expressed our utmost concern
over the escalation we have seen at the
Kerch Straits and the sea of azov and
Russia's continued violations of
international law
we agreed to roll over economic
sanctions against Russia and we stand
ready to further strengthen our support
in particular for the effective area
affected areas of Ukraine and second we
also agreed to work together on tackling
the spread of deliberate large-scale and
systematic disinformation including as
part of hybrid warfare on this eye out
line some of the world leading work that
the UK is doing in this field and I was
clear that after we've left the European
Union the UK will continue to work
closely with our European partners to
uphold the international rules based
system and to keep all our people safe
and that is why it is right that our
brexit deal includes the deepest
security partnership that has ever been
agreed with the EU mr. speaker at this
council I faithfully and firmly
reflected the concerns of this house
over the Northern Ireland backstop I
explained that the assurances we had
already agreed with the EU were
insufficient for this house and we had
to go further in showing that we never
want to use this backstop and if it is
used it must be a temporary arrangement
some of the resulting exchanges at this
council were robust but I make no
apology I make
[Applause]
I make no apology for standing up for
the interests of this house and the
interests
and the interests of our whole united
kingdom in response the eu-27 published
a series of conclusions they made clear
that it is there and I quote firm
determination to work speedily on a
subsequent agreement that establishes by
the 31st of December 2020 alternative
arrangements so that the backstop will
not need to be triggered the house will
forgive me but I think this bears
repeating the backstop will not need to
be triggered
they underlined that if the backstop
were nevertheless to be triggered it
would apply temporarily they said that
in this event the EU would use its best
endeavours to negotiate and conclude
expeditiously a subsequent agreement
that would replace the backstop and they
gave a new assurance in relation to the
future partnership with the UK to make
it even less likely that the backstop
would ever be needed by stating that the
EU stands ready to embark on
preparations immediately after signature
of the withdrawal agreement to ensure
that negotiations can start as soon as
possible after the UK's withdrawal mr.
speaker in these conclusions in their
statements at the council and in their
private meetings with me my fellow EU
leaders could not have been clearer they
do not want to use this backstop they
want to agree the best possible future
relationship with us there is no plot to
keep us in the backstop indeed president
macron said on Friday quote we can
clarify and reassure the backstop is not
our objective it is not a durable
solution and nobody is trying to lock
the UK into the backstop as formal
conclusions from a European Council
these commitments have legal status and
should be welcomed they go further than
the EU has ever done previously in
trying to address the concerns of this
house and of course they sit on top of
the commitments that we have already
negotiated in relation to the backstop
including ensuring the customs element
is UK wide that both sides are legally
committed to using best endeavours to
have our new relationship in place
before the end of the implementation
period that if the new relationship
isn't ready we can choose to extend the
implementation period
stead of the back stop coming into force
that if the back stop does come in we
can use alternative arrangements not
just the future relationship to get out
of it that the treaty is clear the back
stock can only ever be temporary and
that there is an explicit termination
clause but Mr Speaker I know that this
house is still deeply uncomfortable
about the backstop and I understand that
and I want to secure to us to go further
still in the reassurances we secure
discussions with my new partners
including presidents tusk
Janka and others have shown that further
clarification following the council's
conclusions is in fact possible so
discussions are continuing to explore
further political and legal assurances
and we are also looking closely at new
ways of empowering the House of Commons
to ensure that any provision for a
backstop has democratic legitimacy
[Applause]
this is very irregular the statement
must be heard there will be a full
opportunity for exchanges but the
statement by the Prime Minister must be
heard and heard with courtesy the Prime
Minister empowering the House of Commons
to ensure that any provision for a
backstop has democratic legitimacy and
to enable the house to place its own
obligations on the government to ensure
that the backstop cannot be in place
indefinitely but it is now only just
over 14 weeks until the UK leaves the EU
and I know many members many members of
this house are concerned that we need to
take a decision soon by right
[Applause]
my right honourable friend the leader of
the house will set out business on
Thursday in the usual way
[Applause]
[Music]
but I can confirm today that we intend
to return to the meaningful vote debate
in the week commencing 7th of January
and hold the vote the following week mr.
speaker mr. speaker when we have the
vote when we have the vote members will
need to reflect carefully on what is in
the best interests of our country I know
that there are a range of very strongly
held personal views on this issue across
the house and I respect all of them but
expressing our personal views is not
what we are here to do we asked the
British people to take this decision
four hundred four hundred and seventy
two current members of this house voted
for the referendum in June 2015
with just 32 voting against and the
British people responded by instructing
us to leave the European Union similarly
similarly 438 current members of this
house voted to trigger article 52 set to
set the process of our departure in
motion with only 85 of today's members
voting against now we must honor our
duty to finish the job
I know I know this is not everyone's
perfect deal it is a compromise but if
we let met the perfect be the enemy of
the good
then we risk leaving the EU with no
deals
of course of course we have prepared for
No Deal and tomorrow the cabinet will be
discussing the next phase in ensuring
that we are ready for that scenario but
let us not risk for jobs services and
security of the people we serve by
turning our backs on an agreement with
our neighbors that honors the referendum
and provides for a smooth and orderly
exit avoiding No Deal is only possible
if we can reach an agreement or if we
fall or if we abandon brexit entirely
and as I said in the debate earlier this
month do not imagine that if we vote
this down a different deal is going to
miraculously appear if you want proof
look at the conclusions of this council
as president Janka said it is the best
deal possible and the only deal possible
and any any proposal any proposal for
the future relationship whether Norway
Canada or any other variety that has
been mentioned would require agreeing
this withdraw agreement the leader of
the opposition as well as some others
are trying to pretend they could do
otherwise this is a fiction finally let
us not break faith with the British
people by trying to stage another
referendum
another vote which would do irreparable
damage to the integrity of our politics
[Applause]
because it's order there are as many
members of this house including an
illustrious chair of a select committee
who are heckling noisily and Brett mr.
Angus Brendan McNeil you're a cheeky
chappie but we need much less of the
cheek and more by way of courtesy and
listening to the Prime Minister the
Prime Minister thank you another vote
which would do irreparable damage to the
integrity of our politics because it
would say to millions who trusted in
democracy that our democracy does not
deliver another vote which would likely
leave us no further forward than the
last and another vote which would
further divide our country at the very
moment we should be working to united
and let us not let us not follow the
leader of the Opposition in thinking
about what gives him the best chance of
forcing a general election
for at this critical moment at this
critical moment in our history we should
be thinking not about our party's
interests but about the national
[Applause]
let us let us find a way to come
together and work together in the
national interest to see this brexit
through Mr Speaker I will work
tirelessly over these next few weeks to
fulfill my responsibilities as Prime
Minister to find a way forwards over the
last two weeks I've met quite a number
of colleagues and I'm happy to continue
to do so on this important issue so we
can fulfill our responsibilities to the
British people so together we can take
back control of our borders laws
[Applause]
while protecting the jobs the security
and the integrity of our precious United
Kingdom so together we can move on to
finalizing the future relationship with
the European Union and the trade deals
with the rest of the world that can fuel
our prosperity for years to come and so
together we can get this brexit done and
shift the national focus to our domestic
priorities investing in our NHS our
schools and housing tackling the
injustice this is that so many still
face and building a country that truly
works for everyone for these are the
ways these are the ways in which
together this house wills best serve the
interests of the British people and I
commend this statement
[Applause]
Thank You mr. Speaker I thank the Prime
Minister for advance copy of her
statement on Ukraine as NATO has said we
need both sides to show restraint and
deescalate with international law
adhered to including Russia allowing
unhindered access to Ukraine's ports on
the sea of azov Mr Speaker we face an
unprecedented situation the Prime
Minister has led us into a national
crisis and if any more evidence was
needed of why we face this grave
situation the Prime Minister
demonstrated it last week's summit there
were some warm words drafted and the
Prime Minister even managed to negotiate
those away to replace by words about
preparing for No Deal mr. speaker the
Prime Minister boasted I had a robust
discussion with President Janka but that
cannot hide the cold reality that she
achieved nothing standing at the
despatch-box last week the Prime
Minister said I have made some progress
mr. speaker she has not made any
progress at all the prime minister said
so herself while still in Brussels and I
quote the EU is clear as am i that this
is the deal the European Commission has
been categorical it will not be
negotiated the EU Council has given the
clarification that were possible at this
stage so no further meetings with the UK
are foreseen the deal is unchanged and
not going to change the house must get
on with the vote and move on to consider
the realistic alternatives there
Hanabi there can be no logical reason
for this delay except that in taking
shambolic government to a new level the
Prime Minister no longer has the backing
of her cabinet the international trade
secretary suggested that the Prime
Minister's deal no longer has the
backing of the cabinet it's worth
quoting his words and I quote I think
that it is very difficult to support the
deal if we don't get changes to the
backstop I don't think it will get
through I'm not even sure if the cabinet
will agree for it to be put to the House
of Commons so we had the spectacle of
the last few days with numerous cabinet
members coming forward with their own
alternatives the international trade
secretary suggested that a two-year
transition is - No Deal is an option the
work in pension secretary says the
government needs to try something
different and build a consensus in
Parliament the Attorney General is
reported as saying he wants her gone and
for the deal to be renegotiated while
the International Development Secretary
is allegedly liaison with the ERG to
launch an alternative option others are
reportedly working on a second
referendum but even if cabinet no longer
backs the deal then who knows what the
options would be so can the Prime
Minister answer this one does her deal
still have the confidence of the cabinet
- is cabinet collective responsibility
still in operation
[Music]
three does it remain government policy
to avoid a no deal outcome mr. speaker
an unacceptable deal is on the table
no amendment has been secured
renegotiations have been rebuffed and
not even mere assurances have been
offered and the Prime Minister's shoddy
deal no longer even has the backing of
the cabinet the Prime Minister ran away
from putting a deal before Parliament
because even our own cabinet has doubts
and she herself admits Parliament won't
back it so we're left edging ever closer
to the 29th of March deadline without a
deal and without even an agreed planning
cabinet to get a deal the Prime
Minister's has cynically run down the
clock trying to manoeuvre Parliament
into a choice between two unacceptable
outcomes her Deal or No Deal the country
workers and businesses are increasingly
anxious even yesterday the CBI said
uncertainty is throttling firms and
threatening jobs not in the future but
right now the British Chamber of
Commerce has said there is no time to
waste a responsible prime minister would
for the good of this country have put
this deal before the house this week
this week so we could move on from this
government's disastrous negotiations
this mr. speaker is a constitutional
crisis and the Prime Minister is the
architect of it she's leading the most
shambolic and chaotic government in
modern British history even cabinet no
longer functions a prime minister whose
authority has been lost a cabinet a
cabinet disintegrated into cliques and
factions and a Conservative Party so
fundamentally split that it's very
existence is being discussed it is clear
mr. speaker the Prime Minister has
failed to negotiate a deal failed to get
any meaningful reassurances there is no
excuse for any more dither or delay this
government
this government mr. speaker has already
become the first government in British
history to be held in contempt by
Parliament the debate on the meaningful
vote was pulled at the last minute and
the Prime Minister has now wasted five
weeks having achieved nothing not a
single word renegotiated not a single
reassurance gained this last week has
embodied the failure chaos and
indecision at the heart of this
government's shambolic handling of
brexit today they've been dragged
kicking and screaming to announce a date
to restart the debate but mr. speaker it
is
this far mr. Ennis you're a
distinguished ornament of a government
department a representative of the
executive branch be good man you could
do so much better when you try mr.
jeremy corbyn but Mr Speaker it is
disgraceful that a month has been wasted
since we were due to vote on the 11th of
December there can be no further
attempts to dodge the accountability of
government to this Parliament mr.
speaker
[Applause]
mr. speaker the right honorable
gentleman asked me three questions
during that response does the deal still
have the confidence of the cabinet yes
does cabinet collective responsibility
still apply yes does does the cabinet
want to avoid No Deal yes the government
wants to ensure that we leave the
European Union with a good deal and that
is this
the real indecision is the indecision at
the heart of a Labour Party that has no
plan and no
[Applause]
and the nashville national crisis is an
opposition that is irresponsible to push
his party interests or the interests of
the british people
[Applause]
[Music]
it's rendering Mitchell it is clear mr.
speaker is it not a deal which my right
honourable friend has so assiduously
negotiated is most unlikely to secure
the support of this House of Commons in
these circumstances does she not think
it would be wiser to seek an extension
to article 50
[Music]
order having the order having the right
honourable gentleman shattered our
live-in gently say to a government with
don't stand near the chair and shout at
your colleagues if you're going to do
that leave the chamber we'll manage
perfectly adequately without you mr.
Andrew Mitchell to see to seek an
extension to article 50 rather than to
leave with No Deal friend but I don't
think it's right to be seeking that
extension of of article 50 I think what
we our faith what Parliament will be
faced with is a decision to exercise its
responsibility to deliver on the
referendum vote to deliver brexit I
continue to believe that this is a good
deal yes we are seeking those further
reassurances but I continue to believe
that we can leave with a good deal and
that this is it mr. Ian Blackford thank
you Thank You mr. speaker and I thank
the prime minister further advance a to
her statement but I have to ask where is
the leadership the phrase which is often
used we thought the Prime Minister had
reached rock bottom but she's still
digging mr. speaker we have for sitting
days left in this place before the
Christmas recess we have them left with
the narrow window when we return in
January to find if we forward
I took the government's brexit timetable
it cannot be done after two years of
negotiation the Prime Minister has
designed a deal that she knows that she
cannot deliver it doesn't have the
support of this house mr. speaker it is
time to call time on this government
is a laughing stock companies and their
workers do not know if we're going to be
crashing out of the European Union in
three months time we've just over 100
days 100 days to prepare for the risk of
an ordeal that most sensible folk would
reject as being unacceptable
the Prime Minister is playing a game of
brinksmanship the European Council
President Donald Tusk was clear when he
said I have no mandate to organize any
further negotiations what more does the
Prime Minister need to hear to know that
our deal is dead
this is embarrassing the Prime Minister
might be prepared to be employed as for
the shambles
but the rest of us are not Parliament
needs to take control of this situation
and seek to find a solution that
prevents or risk the jobs and prosperity
it's the people of our countries that we
are talking about today Prime Minister
tells us that there are no other options
that is not the case standing before
Parliament ruling out another referendum
on EU membership is an act of
desperation from the Prime Minister
knowing that she cannot get her own deal
through this place the Prime Minister
wants to silence debate having taken
away Parliament's voice her rights are
meaningful votes now the Prime Minister
wants us to take the right of the people
to vote away their democratic right to
have their say their democratic right to
change their mind
Mr Speaker I plead to the Prime Minister
to put all options back on the table
stop operating in isolation reach out
and speak with the opposition parties we
all have a responsibility to protect our
citizens it is time Prime Minister to
move beyond narrow party politics
it is time to operate in the interests
of all our nation's I asked the Prime
Minister to bring forward the meaningful
vote on her deal before the Christmas
research there's no reason to delay let
us have that meaningful vote this week
and lastly will she do the right thing
and meet with me and other opposition
party leaders this week collectively
this justice speaker is the true test of
this government's world if we are to
believe that we have a partnership of
equals then note today we must be heard
[Music]
well first of all I'm happy to say to
the right honourable gentleman if he
wants to come to talk to me about this
issue I'm happy to talk to him about it
but we do have a fundamental difference
of opinion that was revealed in the
response of his party to what I said in
my statement I believe we should deliver
leaving the EU for the British people I
believes we should stay in the EU so
that's a fundamental difference that we
have there he talked about putting jobs
and prosperity first this deal does just
that but it delivers on the referendum
while protecting jobs and prosperity he
says he doesn't want to leave with no
deal well the only way to ensure that
you leave with leave without having no
deal is to support a deal and can I just
can I just remind the right honorable
gentleman gently that 56% of Scots voted
for pro brexit parties named Cheryl
Gillan
[Applause]
the Independent Commission on
referendums published earlier this year
and recommended that any second
referendum on a subject should be
specified in the legislation enabling
the first referendum say that the
requirement for or possibility of a
second referendum and the reason for it
is clear to the electorate before the
first vote takes place would the Prime
Minister agreed that no such provision
was made and that calling for a second
referendum at this stage is merely a
ruse to try and reverse the result
[Applause]
Thank You mr. speaker can I say to my
right honourable friend that I'm
grateful to her for pointing that out to
the to the house of course it is
absolutely the case that there was no
suggestion when the referendum was put
to the people in 2016 that that might be
a second referendum people were told
they were led to believe that their vote
would be delivered by the government of
the other time subsequently and that's
what I believe it is certainly in our
interests as a government to do to
deliver on that vote and leave the
European Union
Vincent cable the Prime Minister may be
aware that the the bookmakers has been
offering 66 to 1 against a deal passing
Parliament but even money on a
referendum and even money on the hood
then winning it could it be that the
cabinet ministers who were known
repairing for a referendum are not being
disloyal to her but simply better at
maths
[Laughter]
I'm not sure I'm not sure the right
honourable gentleman should spend too
much time in the betting shops I'm not
sure the odds on the Liberal Democrats
are very good at all
so William cash Thank You mr. speaker
but will the Prime Minister confirm
despite the European councils own
so-called legal endorsement to the
withdrawal agreement which they states
is not so good for renegotiation that as
respects the UK itself this agreement
has not been initialed all signed by
herself as Prime Minister and is only a
draft being no more than a political
agreement under which nothing is agreed
until everything is agreed including the
backstop and therefore she can still
walk away
I can certainly confirm while my friend
that obviously this is the deal that has
been negotiated between the UK and the
European Union but it does have to go
through certain processes in order to be
ratified part of that is ratification
here in the United Kingdom Parliament
and parties ratification and the
European Union European Parliament and
of course it is those processes that
lead to the final agreement and the
withdrawal agreement is Rajan Dobbs
I'm sure the Prime Minister will agree
that EU council conclusions and
declarations are of course political
statements and they've talked about
clarifications reassurances but ruled
out renegotiating contradicting or
reopening the legal texts indeed they
even struck out language saying that the
back stop didn't represent a desirable
outcome for the eu-27 so will the Prime
Minister today tell us exactly and
precisely what she is actually asking
for to deliver on the key concerns about
the legally binding indefinite nature of
the backstop with no right for this
country to exit it on its own terms what
I am asking for is to ensure that we can
deal with the concerns that the right
honourable gentleman and other members
of this house have expressed about the
issue of whether the backstop will could
be indefinite or would be indefinite so
that's two ways to deal with that the
first is to ensure that old arrangements
aport in place to ensure the backstop is
not triggered in the first place and the
second is to ensure that if it is
triggered then
is only temporary and it is further
assurances as I said in my statement
political and legal assurances in
relation to those issues which can be
achieved in a number of ways but it's
further political and legal assurances
in relation to those issues that I'm
seeking just in greening Thursday it
will be a hundred days until Britain
leaves the European Union at the moment
we have no deal and no plan B this is a
constitutional crisis because this house
is not being allowed to express its
world on behalf of our communities who
around the country are telling us that
they reject this deal that is why MPs
want to be able to vote against it so
can I say to the prime minister that
it's though it's pointless criticising
other members in this house who are
coming up with other solutions whether a
second referendum whether Canada whether
Norway we are as a parliament trying to
find a solution through the political
cul-de-sac and mess that we now find
this country in it was clear back in the
summer that the Prime Minister's deal
was not going to succeed she now isn't
just listening she's not allowing debate
this is
totally unacceptable well she agreed to
bring her vote before this house before
Christmas so that she can reflect on the
outcome over the Christmas break I say
to my right honorable friend and I know
that she and I I think have a difference
of opinion in relation to the issue of a
second referendum but can I say to my
right honourable friend but of course
I've indicated when the vote will be
brought back to the house there will be
necessary for the usual channels to
agree what the business motion would be
and how many what level how many days of
debate would be available for that we're
not trying to stop debate what I am
trying to do
[Applause]
was I what I am doing is recognizing and
reflecting to the European Union the
concerns expressed here in this house
and seeking ways in which we can ensure
that members of this house have
sufficient confidence that those
particular concerns have been addressed
mr. Hillery Ben
thank you very much indeed mr. speaker
the Prime Minister went to the European
councils seeking legal assurances and
returned with none and the next council
meeting scheduled is in the third week
of March
now that cabinet ministers are openly
speculating about what should happen
when her deal is defeated can she tell
the house what purpose it serves to
continue to pretend that we might leave
the European Union without an agreement
when she knows better than anyone else
have damaging and disastrous it would be
and when she told the house just now
that it would risk the jobs services and
security of the people responded on this
point previously we do have this house
has a responsibility and it will have a
responsibility to come to a decision on
this matter and to determine whether to
leave the European Union with a deal or
what or to leave without a deal or there
will be those in this house and will try
to ensure that actually we stay in the
European Union I think that would be
wrong I think we should be leaving the
European Union because that's what
people voted for in the biggest exercise
of democracy in our history and I
believe that we should be leaving with a
good deal and this is it
mr. Dominic robbed the final steps of
contingency planning the departure on
WTO terms are essential in case
EU intransigence continues can the Prime
Minister confirm that all of those
necessary actions are now being taken to
Sears to any short-term disruption
including acts at action to prepare for
extra checks at the border by version of
flow to friendlier ports liberalisation
of towered schedules and cutting taxes
for businesses he's trying to tempt me
into some budgetary decisions there
which as he will know would not be
appropriate at this despatch-box but
what I would say to him is that we are
making the plans for the contingency
arrangements for No Deal as I said in my
statement the cabinet will be meeting
tomorrow to discuss what further steps
need to be taken we have already stepped
up those preparations as my might on her
friend indeed
was responsible for himself when he was
the brexit secretary of state but
further stepping up of those No Deal
preparations has gone on to address
exactly the sorts of issues that he's
looking at such as the flow of traffic
into different ports here in the UK to
ease the disruption disruption will take
place in No Deal
in the short term we want to take every
step that we can to mitigate that
I met Cooper the Prime Minister ruled
out of customs union the Prime Minister
ruled out Norway ruled out Canada ruled
out parliamentary votes on her
objectives ruled out parliamentary votes
on the options he's ruling out now
extending article 50 and yet everyone
knows she does not have support for her
plan and she has no assurances from the
EU that she asked for if she carries on
like this she's the one that will take
us over a No Deal
this Christmas businesses and
departments across the country are going
to be spending billions and pounds now
preparing for No Deal doesn't she have a
duty and a responsibility
No Deal to say she will extend article
15 and have a proper discussion in
Parliament
say to the right honorable lady first of
all she says that we ruled out certain
things actually the British people in
the vote that took place in 2016 and one
of the key issues in that was bringing
an end to free movement which some of
those suggestions that she has as
alternatives would not allow to happen
so actually we're trying to reflect the
views that would took place during that
vote and the decision the decision the
decision as to whether we go forward
with the deal or not will be one that
this Parliament will take Thank You mr.
Weil my right honourable friend
continues to negotiate changes to the
backstop would she agree with me that if
those efforts were unfortunately to fail
and if we are to avoid leaving without a
deal which we must at all costs avoid it
must now be critical will she not agree
that we build a consensus in this house
and forge a compromise that delivers
brexit whilst protecting British jobs
and interests
well I agree with my right honourable
friend that the aim of everything that
we are doing and the aim of what this
house will do I believe should be to
ensure that we deliver on that vote and
do it in a way that protects jobs and
prosperity for people up and down this
country that's exactly what we're
working for and I hope that every member
of this house will consider that when it
comes to looking at whether or not we
should support this deal I believe we
should because it does exactly what my
right honorable friend has suggested
this candle
let me tell the prime minister walk is
irresponsible delaying a vote on her
agreement not because she's going to get
any changes to it but because she wants
to run down the clock and try intimidate
to avoid No Deal this isn't acting in
the national interest but in her
personal injury
and I say to the Honourable lady but
what I believe would not have been right
would be for me not to have listened to
the concerns that were expressed in this
house I did listen to those concerns and
I am working and discussions are
continuing with the European Union in
relation to how we address those
concerns and then it will be for
Parliament to decide but that will be at
that point Parliament members of this
house will have a responsibility to
determine whether or not they know the
decision that they come to will be about
whether or not to deliver on the vote of
the referendum in a way that jobs
protects jobs and our security Sir
Michael Fallon given that the Prime
Minister has listened and is still
trying to improve the deal would that
deal not be more palatable
if the timetable for starting on and
agreeing the terms of future trade was
as firm and as legally binding as the
timetable for paying over all the
billions my friend makes a very
important point we have achieved
obviously from the council conclusions
there has been some further progress in
relation to the EU's commitment to the
starting the next stage of negotiations
but my honourable friend has raised an
issue which is exactly one which I think
it is important for us to continue to
discuss with them about getting that
absolute confirmation and certainty he
refers to legal certainty as to when
those negotiations can start and when it
is the determination of both parties to
ensure those negotiations end we want
that trade deal in place and I wanted
him place by the under cember 2020 Neil
grey very much mr. speaker she said for
two years that no deal is better than a
bad deal of course now we know why we
know why her deal is a disaster we'll
never pass this house so as she
desperately tries to light the clock
tell take down will she published her no
deal planning
but I have been clear and I remain clear
that no deal is better than a bad deal
but I believe this is a good deal
John read word he now published the
tariff schedule for the UK for a WTO
exit will that include zero tariffs on
all components coming in for manufacture
here to provide yet another great boost
to Britain as a big manufacturing center
[Applause]
obviously I think I say to my right
honourable friends that these issues are
ones that would have to be addressed in
relation to a No Deal
to a No Deal scenario we are continuing
to discuss as a government the plans
that we need to put in place to deal
with the possibility of a No Deal in
order to mitigate the disruption that
would occur in a No Deal situation and
obviously we will be looking closely at
the tariff schedules Ben Bradshaw how
much will it cost the NHS our other
public services and thousands of
businesses up and down this country as
they are forced to activate their No
Deal contingency plans because of her
reckless time-wasting
the right honorable gentleman
responsible government is about ensuring
that contingency arrangements are put in
place that is the responsible thing
which which any government in this
situation would do to ensure that those
contingency arrangements are in place
until we have the outcome and know with
certainty what is happening on the 28th
whether we're leaving with the deal or
with No Deal we need to make those
contingency arrangements that's the
right thing to do
estimate way after tomorrow's cabinet
meeting where No Deal preparations will
be high on the agenda will the Prime
Minister please arrange for a minister
to come to this house to give a
statement this week and then every week
until we leave the EU so that we know
what's happening so the country can be
reassured business and individuals that
is vital they are happening and this
house needs to know what is happening
I think can I say to my right honorable
friend that obviously she's raising the
important point of information being
available to this house and to members
of this house on the planning that is
taking place of course there are a
number of ways in which that is
expressed to the house the Secretary of
State for exiting the European Union
appears before the Select Committee and
responds to issues on that and of course
these are matters which have been
addressed in debates with within this
house but I understand the point she's
making about wanting to ensure that
members of this house are aware of the
arrangements to being put in place right
field
this house doesn't need more time to
debate but to vote on the various
options before it might she not
therefore agree that we vote as soon as
possible on the amendments the speaker
will choose of those tables and if she's
unwilling to do that might the
opposition parties think how they can
use their time they have to debate on
the floor of the house to actually you
make that bring forward that vote and if
members actually agree with this line of
action might they sign the motion that's
on the order paper in my name
first question obviously the intention
needs to have a proper number of days
for debate when the vote is brought back
in in January at that stage at that
stage of course how the matter is put
before the house will depend on the
further discussions that have taken
place with the European Union and as
we've always said any any motion on this
issue is of course amendable by members
of the of the House England it told the
United Kingdom doesn't want the backstop
we're told the European Union doesn't
want to enter the backstop
what on earth is stopping the European
Union giving us a legal guarantee but
such a backstop would only last for a
very short
[Applause]
- right on boyfriend it is exactly it is
exactly that further legal further
political and legal assurance that we're
looking at in relation to this there
have been very clear statements from the
European Union in relation to this
those have been reiterated after the not
only in the council conclusions but
after the council conclusions as well
the best way to stop the back stop
coming into place of course is to have a
firm date for introducing the future
relationship that is currently the
intention is that is currently 31st of
December 2020 and will be continued
continuing to discuss what further
assurances we can get on this point
screws loosely and precisely will the
Prime Minister be securing this miracle
on 34th Street sir guarantee from the
European Union that she's going to come
back with on the back stop before the
7th of January if she does come back
with that will the house be debating it
on a fresh government motion and in
terms of her commitment to come back on
the 7th of January to start the debate
is that a promise gentlemen first of all
the nature of the business motion will
of course and the nature way in which
the debate is to be dealt with by this
house will of course be discussed with
the usual through the usual channels I
said we would be starting that debate in
the in that first week with the vote in
the following week the right Andhra
gentleman asked me about the timetable
discussions are continuing with the
European Union and I expect those to
continue into the new year
dr. sarah Wollaston here's what would do
irreparable damage to the integrity of
our politics and that is to run down the
clock and to end up forcing through a
deal a which 48 percent didn't want
because they didn't want to leave the
European Union but also the majority of
those who voted for brexit don't want
the mathematics of this just simply
don't stack up the majority in this
house and in the wider country doesn't
want this deal and so can I ask the
Prime Minister to get on with it so that
we can actually vote on this and then
look at practical alternatives tray to
my own prevent that as I've indicated in
my statement we will bring that vote
back in the second week in January the
debate with debate it's our intention
that debate will start in the previous
week in the first week of first week of
January I think it is important as I
said earlier that I have listened to the
house I suspect honourable members had I
not listened to the house and been
starting the work to try and get those
further assurances from members of this
house and then that would have been an
issue that people would have raised I
think it's right that I am the
government are doing exactly what we
said we would which is working with the
EU for those further political and legal
assurances speaker we no nor what the
plan is having failed to win support for
the deal in Parliament and having failed
to get any meaningful change to it that
the European Council last week the Prime
Minister now simply wants to run down
the clock and intimidate Parliament
absolutely to choosing between a bad
deal and the disaster of no deal I put
it to the Prime Minister that it is
wrong to threaten and intimidate
Parliament in Israel
more importantly it is reckless
to take options off the table as she's
tried to do today that could prevent the
disaster of New Deal for the country
what over the point at which this house
faced the meaningful vote it will be a
decision for members of this house as to
whether to accept the deal or to whether
to you know there's some who would
prefer to see action taken so that we
don't leave the European Union I think
that would be wrong I think it would be
right what I believe is right is that we
deliver on the referendum and the
question will be for members of this
house as to whether they accept that
responsibility to come to a decision at
the moment there being lots of ideas
around this house about what should
happen know alternatives that are no
alternatives that actually deliver on
the referendum that deliver on the
referendum in a way that protects jobs
that's what the deal does but it will be
a decision for individual members of
this house to bear the responsibility
that they have it's all of the heels the
Prime Minister will be aware that those
of us who have large manufacturing
companies in our constituencies in my
case Johnson Matthey and Royston who do
integrated manufacture on a European
places with short supply lines they're
getting on to people like me saying look
it's very urgent that we have a deal now
when she's negotiating and discussing in
Europe with people like mr. Juncker does
she have the feeling that there is that
urgent need to get a deal and that they
are prepared to listen to what she says
has really put in a chip because I must
say that when I saw him looking so
relaxed and really being rather
patronizing
I felt that wasn't really putting in the
sort of shift that she has can I say to
my right humble friend that indeed the I
think very clear message that comes back
from the European Union from the
Commission and EU leaders is that they
do want a deal we have obviously
negotiated this deal there are those
further assurances I'm working to
achieve and it has been made clear by
President Juncker and others that those
further discussions can indeed take
place at least several Roberts the prime
minister knows that no better deal will
be found in Europe and that no majority
will be found in Westminster she also
knows no deal is disastrous she delayed
a vote because she knew her deal would
fail to get the support it needed she
can employ the same logic again well she
confirmed that she holds the power to
seek an extension for article 50 it is
of course it is of course well first of
all the government does not the
government holds their power to seek an
extension for article 50 by any
extension of article 50 which have to be
agreed with the European Union the PERT
I I have been clear I have been clear
that what I believe is the right course
of action having triggered article 50
having undertaken the negotiations is
that we ensure we leave the European
Union on the timetable that we've
already set out Nicky Morgan you very
much indeed mr. speaker the Prime
Minister and her statement talked about
empowering this house but the trouble is
is that she is asking this house to
accept a deferral for several weeks of
the meaningful vote on the draft
withdraw agreement on the basis that
further assurances can be agreed with
the European Union but there is nothing
in what she has said today or what has
been reported in the EU Council those
further assurances are likely to be
given and I say this is somebody who was
going to vote for her draft agreement on
the base of the she has set out the
businesses need certainty and the
country needs reassurance I honestly do
not think the businesses and employers
and our constituents will understand why
this house is going on holiday
when we should be having the meaningful
vote this week I say to my right
honourable friend I believe it is what I
believe is right is that what the
government is doing is having heard the
concerns that are expressed have been
expressed by members of this house what
what the government is doing is taking
those concerns to the European Union yes
we have further statements from the u EU
with legal status in the council
conclusions than we've had before but we
are seeking yet more and further
assurances from the European Union I
think that's the right thing to do then
that can be debated properly by this by
this house and the vote taken Johanna
cherry last Thursday the Attorney
General told the house that he was
reviewing the question of whether
article 50 could be revoked by a simple
vote of this house or by legislation
this Thursday the Scottish case has been
referred back from the Court of Justice
to the court in Edinburgh to look at
this issue can the Prime Minister
confirm for us that the government's
position on how article 50 could be
revoked
whether legislation are simply a vote of
this house is required will be set out
to the courts on Admiral on Thursday can
I say to the Honourable lady that I will
look into that issue and get back to her
on the specifics of that issue in terms
of the stance that the government is
taking in relation to the case that is
going to the court in Edinburgh as but I
I know the Honorable lady has had
considerable interest in the revocation
of article 50 I would simply remind all
members of this house that the
revocation of article 50 is something
that this government has said we will
not do because rebek provoking article
50 means staying in the European Union
johnathan generally you mr. speaker and
I was one of the members who would and
will support the Prime Minister's still
but I have to say Prime Minister that
what's coming back to me from business
from industry from the city is that we
are now hemorrhaging support and
investment on a daily basis and it's
getting worse which is why I add two
other honourable members in saying
please do think again in holding this
vote in holding a series of stand alone
resolutions which mean that we can take
of you and move on I understand the
concern that he's expressing in relation
to business business once certainty
business wants the deal business
welcomed the deal when we when we
negotiated the deal and I think they
still taking that they taking that
approach he referred to a lot of I think
being referred to as indicative votes a
number of motions that could be bought
for this house there are no plans for
indicative votes I have no plans for
indicative votes but can I just say -
can I just say - my honourable friend
and two other members of this house but
actually what is necessary is for the
house to reflect on what members want in
terms of their responsibilities
in terms of their responsibilities in
terms of their responsibility to come to
a decision on this matter and at the
moment there are as I indicated earlier
a number of views around this house some
want to stay in the EU some want to go
for a second referendum some some would
support a No Deal some would support
looking at other arrangements all of
those arrangements any of those
arrangements as I said that would relate
would require a withdrawal agreement
because they were would require us to
make clear the basis on which we're
restoring from the European Union Angela
Smith Prime Minister last week at
Mohnish for his use of the word nebulous
but there are many people in this house
who would take issue with her use of the
word meaningful because there's nothing
meaningful about two votes which forces
members of this house to choose between
her deal and no deal so when is the
Prime Minister gonna stop digging start
listening and building a consensus with
members across the house to get us out
of this map it's always going to be the
case whenever the vote came before this
house that people would have members of
the house would have a decision as to
whether to support the deal that had
been negotiated with the European Union
or not with the consequences that
failure to support that deal would bring
and that is is the same whenever that
vote is taken dr. Julian Lewis does the
Prime Minister recall telling the house
on the 3rd of December that the 3 to 4
billion pound set aside in the budget
for contingency no deal planning was
about to be allocated in the next few
days to relevant departments has that
allocation been made and is the money
now available for essential contingency
plan
yes I do recall saying that I say my own
boyfriend that of course the 1819
financial year allocations are in place
and money is being spent what we I think
he was referring to and I was referring
to his nineteen twenty allocations
negotiations on those are well advanced
a number of departments have settled and
we expect to be in a position to confirm
all of those shortly George house must
Friday a constituent said to me that
although she had voted to leave in the
referendum in 2016
she now wanted to register the fact that
she'd now changed her mind as she put it
for the sake of her grandchildren if it
emerges that a significant number of
people have a previous leave voters have
reached the same conclusion which would
be more democratic now and then the
opportunity to change their mind or
pressing on regardless
and I I also hear from people who've in
the opposite position they voted to
remain and now say they would vote to
leave the European Union the fact is
that simple fact is that if there were a
second referendum which if there were a
second referendum which came out with
the same result would those honorable
members who wish people to be given the
chance to think again continue to say
that there should be a referendum if it
came out with a different result I think
there'll be many people who would say
actually how many referendums shall we
have a new referendum
this is this is we had the referendum
and I believe it's our duty to deliver
on it
Nana Seabury problem is mr. speaker
there is a consensus in the country and
that consensus is is that this is one
wholly unholy mess and a solution has to
be found and the Prime Minister still
hasn't told us what her plan B is does
she not understand if we leave the
European Union not having a people's
vote knowing what brexit looks like and
then it turns out that the people of
this country knowing what wrecks it
looked like didn't want us to leave the
European Union it would be the biggest
betrayal of democracy in this country
the people of this country especially
the young people would never forget nor
forgive us especially this party my own
right honorable friend I know she has
taken a particular view in relation to
this issue but I continue to believe
that what we should be doing is
delivering on the vote it was
overwhelming as I indicated in the
figures that I said in my stair set out
in my statement it was the overwhelming
view of this Parliament that people
should have a vote in the referendum it
was the overwhelming view of this
Parliament that article 15 should be
triggered article 50 leads to leaving
the European Union it is now our duty to
deliver that how does the Prime Minister
have the gall to accuse those of us who
want more democracy of breaking faith
with the public when she has
has turned faith breaking into a new art
form she had promised no general
election last year and then she granted
one she promised no means she promised a
meaningful vote last week and then
canceled it but you cannot break faith
with the British public by asking for
their views why can she not understand
that a people's vote would be the first
opportunity for people to vote on the
facts not on the fantasy and the
publication trying to saves the
Honourable lady that there are many
people up and down this country 17 4.4
million people I think up and down this
country who would say that if the the
vote that took place in 2016 was not
honored by this Parliament that would be
breaking face
Sabeena bother Murray the outcome as our
honorable friends has said it's either
we leave without having an agreement to
leave and transition and future
arrangements or we go somehow back to
having a attempt by some to reverse the
rule of the referendum or we have to
deal with the agreements which should be
negotiated now it's quite clear from
Freddie says asked when the times on
Thursday saying that seven people out of
eight in the country and I suspect here
as well would prefer to have the had the
deal with the agreements in preference
either to dropping out without a deal or
going back to another referendum so I
could say that my prime minister I think
most people support her and we should
too and that actually reflects and
actually reflects the comments that I'm
given up and around the country when
people say to me and write to me and
indicate they want us to get on with it
to deliver and then enable us as a
government as a parliament to get on
with addressing the domestic issues that
matter to them day to day sugar a muna
mr. speaker let us be clear is the long
list of broken promises of leave
campaigners she appointed to her
government which has done irreparable
damage to the integrity of our politics
now she has been here given three
statements and on each occasion this
house is clear it will not vote for her
plan but she continues to refuse to
listen can I ask her a very specific
question if we get to the March EU
council and there's no consensus in this
house on a route forward will she now
commit and she said No Deal is not
something she would countenance will she
now commit at that March 2019 Council to
request an extension to article 52 stop
No Deal from happening
I've indicated my approach in relation
to the extension martica 50
three hands then what's in manual my
course said on Friday recent comments
from the Commission have been rather
more hostile and anything but nebulous
Martin Selma is reported to have told
officials quote losing Northern Ireland
is the price of brexit there sir been
very brief tu ambassadors on the on the
on the deal that so the UK must align
their rules but the EU will retain all
the controls and that the weekend of
further EU officials reported The Times
just said to use a christmas-themed we
want all parties and factions in the
British Parliament to feel the police
Midwinter does this sound to my right on
a friend like people negotiating in good
faith I've always been clear throughout
this these have been tough negotiations
but we but we have held our side and got
achieved a deal that actually delivers
on the vote of the British people
delivers it in a way that protects jobs
and security and I believe protects more
prosperity for the future Stephen
Doughty q mr. speaker is it not the
truth that well the Prime Minister talks
about democracy she prevented the
cabinet having a votes
she's prevents in Parliament having her
votes and she doesn't want the public to
have a vote on this deal so she was talk
about democracy and she should think
very very carefully about that but will
she not admit that she's acting out in a
completely reckless fashion with jobs
with business with investment and with
our constituents features because on the
2nd of January when the vast majority
people in this country will go back to
work this Parliament will not be sitting
the government will still be stalling
for time trying to come up with a magic
solution and people simply be asking
what is going on
he I have to say he asked me a question
in relation to what I was doing and I
have to say my answer to that question
is no certainly we've had our peoples
vote in Lincolnshire yeah here and they
are people by the way yeah
now I expressed an unfashionably
supportive view of the Prime Minister
today I think actually that this matter
is resolved all and many of us who have
been skeptical about the deal so far
could be persuaded to vote for it if
there was a leading legally binding
protocol saying that as is normal with
international treaties if a temporary
arrangement ceases to be temporary then
either side can unilaterally withdraw
and in any event under international law
we would have the right to abrogate
those parts of the treaty if they prove
not to be temporary so I saved the Prime
Minister keep calm and carry on
yeah it's commencin also reflect the
fact that I think he has himself in the
amendment that he puts down to the
motion reflected the view that he has
just expressed and there are many ways
in which we can achieve what everybody I
think who is concerned about the
backstop wants which is to make sure
that if it is used it is only temporary
I want to try to make sure it's not used
at all mr. chairman it's promised aware
that many people in our country feel
that they work on over the read last
referendum by combination of fraudsters
cheats foreign money and assembling
about the real truth of the challenges
our countries faced
did you also know that many of us feel
is tragic to see her so isolated
isolated from her party from this
Parliament and the people in the country
will she change her mind as I have done
and go for a people's boat and a
people's choice all the facts not on the
theory no I've I've already made my
views clear I mentioned it in this
statement in relation to the concept of
a second referendum I think we should be
delivering on the referendum that took
place in 2016
so you go Squire Brenda said she's going
to be stepping up work to mitigate any
disruption in the event of a no deal and
the cabinet will be discussing that
tomorrow given the fact there are just
over 100 days to go we have the
Christmas in the New Year break can she
informed this house and the watching
country how many meetings of Cobra there
will be how many she will chair and
whether there will be meetings
throughout the Christmas and New Year
break of cabinet ministers on Cobra to
plan for this here I say to my other
friend have already been fortnightly
meetings taking place that will move to
a more regular rhythm in in January as
we continue to step up the preparations
for No Deal the Prime Minister ruling
out a second referendum when we haven't
actually implemented the first can I
also congrats to know that she didn't
get her hair it's roughly by president
Younker the way he seems to do to
everybody but can I just ask her has she
had a word with her Chancellor of the
Exchequer who really when he called
people who voted leave seventeen point
four million people he implied they were
extremists have you had a word with him
to make sure that he is not going to
take that attitude to decent people
across the country
nobody in everybody in this government
recognizes that people went out this
Parliament gave people the decision
whether or not to leave people went out
in seventeen point four million people
chose that we should leave the European
Union they did so for a variety of
reasons ending free movement was for
many of them but just also for many of
them I think that concept of wanting a
United Kingdom able to stand independent
in the world make those trade deals
around the rest of the world but free of
the bureaucracy of Brussels was another
reason why people wanted to do that they
did that with their hearts and with
their heads and with the best of
intentions and it's our job to actually
deliver on the vote that they gave Jacob
Murray smog by your leave mr. speaker
now I congratulate the Prime Minister on
winning the confidence of the
Conservatives in this house
[Music]
and a sha ha and assure her that she
therefore commands my confidence to only
issue at the second referendum better
known as the losers vote I support the
Prime Minister's opposition to this not
only because it is undemocratic and
would be divisive but also because it
would be very hard to deny a second
referendum in Scotland if we had a
second referendum on membership of the
RK news
can I say my my honorable friend I think
makes a good point we have a record and
Dave over the years on a number of
referendums we have accepted the
decisions that people have taken we have
not gone back to them with a second
referendum and I think he's absolutely
writing may I thank him for his remarks
at the beginning of this question we be
told there's going to be a thirty four
day delay from when we were supposed to
have the meaningful vote last Tuesday
until the new date now on the 14th of
January that's clearly not going to be
any substantive changes to the
withdrawal agreement we all know what
the outcome of that vote would be and
it's irresponsible for the prime
minister to prolong this uncertainty
while not ruling out a No Deal press it
further to the question from my humble
friend from Exeter who might ask her
again what is the cost to our country of
pressing the button on the No Deal
contingency plans which we know many
businesses and public services across
the country including our NHS now have
to trigger before Christmas say to the
Honourable lady the same answer that I
gave to the right honourable friend
the member for Exeter which is that
these are plans that it is sensible for
government to make as contingency
arrangements in the circumstances that
we have if the Honourable lady and other
members of this house wish to ensure
that we don't leave the European Union
without a deal and the only way to do
that is to support a deal
before Thank You mr. speaker
27 prime ministers across Europe have
agreed unanimously to offer the UK the
deepest trade agreement they have ever
offered five of those Prime Minister's
upon sister parties to the British
Labour Party seven of them from sister
parties to the British Liberal Democrat
Party there's our prime minister agree
that for the best way to avoid a hard
brexit the best way for parties opposite
to avoid that is to look again at the
deal that has been offered by prime
ministers of bossy oh yes can I can I
echo the comments of my honorable friend
I think she's absolutely right and I
understand there are those in those
sister parties two parties on the
opposition benches who have been talking
to them and encouraging them to see that
this is a deal that does deliver a far
wider and more ambitious trading
arrangement and has ever been offered to
any other third country who Stella
Creasy mr. speaker for weeks now the
Prime Minister's been clear about what
her deal is for weeks now the European
Union has been clear about what deal
they will offer for weeks now this house
has been clear about what they will
reject but it's not true that nothing
has changed because it's very clear what
little support the Prime Minister had
left on her own benches is ebbing away
by the hour because when we know
the chair if you want gentlemen but it's
not happening is it because we know the
quicker we take the deal the longer we
will have to prepare for whatever the
outcome of that vote is and the British
public watching us go away on holiday
without having made any progress on this
will not forgive any of us for goodness
sake Prime Minister stop wasting all of
our time get on table headphones and let
us prepare for what comes next
my face the Honourable lady it is not
correct to say that no progress has been
made but I want to see further progress
being made and that's what I'm going to
be working on James Turner inch mr.
speaker the drop with rule agreements
585 pages long and whilst I appreciate I
don't necessarily agree with the case
for not producing the floor plan for a
managed no-till brexit if the withdraw
agreement does fail in this house how
quick it will it be to that full no-till
preparation being published after the
withdraw agreement is rejected the the
formal position as I'm sure my humble
friend will recall is that if that deal
is rejected then the government has a
limited period of time number of sitting
days with which to bring forward its
proposals for the next stage for dealing
with that situation before this before
this house and that is a timetable
obviously which we would meet Peter Kyle
this lengthy statement that the Prime
Minister made today it was interesting
that the one passage he leaked to the
press yesterday was her antagonism
towards the idea of a people's vote it
is entirely consistent with her approach
to this in the start where she took this
house to the Supreme Court to stop us
having a say at the beginning withdrew
the vote last week at the end can I just
beg the Prime Minister that in the next
few weeks if she is going to pause and
stop and prevaricate can she use that
time to start listening engaging to
people in this house and to the
anxieties her felt out there in the
public for the very first time can she
gage and listen I've made the point
about listening to the house that's why
that further discussions are taking
place but as I said in my statement I am
happy of course to speak with with
people in this house I've been speaking
with quite a few of my colleagues over
the last last couple of weeks and I'm
happy to continue to speak with
colleagues about how we can ensure that
we do deliver for the vote that we
deliver it and that we deliver a good
brexit so those from Swain shouldn't her
recent experiences at the council serve
as a powerful corrective to any illusion
anyone could have that we could have
remained members of it my right
honourable friend I think makes an an
interesting point and I suspect that
what he saw actually fed into the
concerns that many of those seventeen
point four million people had when they
voted to leave she's having Goodman
afternoon on a cross-party basis sixty
members of parliament have written to
the prime minister asking her to rule
out No Deal
she knows the costs what possible reason
can she have for not doing it now the
only way to rule out No Deal is to agree
a deal
[Applause]
Nick Herbert Thank You mr. speaker the
Prime Minister is surely right to seek
further assurances on the backstop which
after all is what many right honourable
and honourable members on both sides of
this house asked her to do is it not the
case that most honourable members who
are supporting now having voted in most
cases to trigger article 50 but
nevertheless they are supporting now a
second referendum
I'll doing so working on the heroic
assumption that remain is likely to win
have they stopped for one second to
consider the possibility but leave my
twin or worst of all that we would have
another very narrow result that would
give uncertainty to this country for
months and years
my right honorable friend makes a very
important point about the uncertainty
that would come to this country I
believe a second referendum would be as
I've said before I've described it as as
divisive it wouldn't necessarily be
decisive but I do think that many people
who assume that it would come with a
remain decision actually underestimate
the character of the British people
whose view I think for many people would
be we gave a very clear message we
wanted to leave and we'll vote even in
even greater numbers to do so the reason
why the EU are clinging limpet lake to
this agreement is that they know they
have got concessions in this agreement
which will enable them well it comes to
the future trailer range months to
extract even more concessions from the
UK government and would she not be far
better not walk away with 939 billion in
her pocket her hands-free and able to do
the kind of work which any governments
you want to do to make this country
prosperous what is being made clear to
the government is that it isn't the case
that in all circumstances we've in a no
deal circumstance we would not have any
financial liabilities there would be
some financial liabilities for this for
this government of course the 39 billion
is the negotiated settlement in
relationships withdrawal agreement but
the would be financial liabilities even
in a no deal situation
Heidi Allen mr. speaker it's actually
not just the backstop that worries
colleagues myself included for me
actually it's the lack of legal
certainty over what our future trade
deals might look like because that
political declaration is not legally
binding so any one of the you country
leaders including our own should we have
a different leader could rip it up and
we could be sparring to a No Deal breaks
it at any time the Prime Minister's said
it's not about our views I actually I
agree with her that's why she's appealed
to the country directly with her deal is
why I must represent my constituents but
if she really believes in the views of
constituents being the most important
thing then surely the right thing to do
dare I say the democratic thing to do
is to be honest and grown-up and display
proper engagement with people and that
means checking with them that they are
content with her deal my own boyfriend I
think the arguments she puts about
listening to people and equally be put
about listening to people in relation to
the first referendum that was held on
2016 can I also say to my humble friend
though that she raises an important
point about the nature of the political
declaration and that concern is another
issue which I have been raising with the
European Union because I want to ensure
that an honorable and right onward
members of this house are able to have
full confidence in that future trade
agreement
Angus Brendon Neil she made a deal with
the EU about Ireland 70 quite rights to
keep it at a cage of her own making to
make sure the UK cannot mark slighted
his commitments because last week the
eu-27 will have noticed the sleek it way
her government changed the laws move the
goalposts when dealing with Scotland in
the Supreme Court the realities were
once Britannia said it ruled the waves
now we see the Firoz as we've seen with
Scotland the EU s big fear is that when
given the chance but China will waive
the rules as are we on holiday before it
makes any vote on any deal can I say to
the Honourable gentleman I think he's
referring to the bill that Scottish
Parliament brought forward which was
challenging the changes that were made
in relation to his drawler Act but I
think that that in relation to the
relationship between the withdrawal act
and the Scottish Scottish Parliament and
decisions in relation to Scotland
honourable members from the SNP were
aware and indeed the Scottish Government
was aware of the position when they
brought that bill before the Scottish
[Applause]
and religion and Kim mr. speaker despite
assurances from the Prime Minister that
the backstop would be temporary I remain
very concerned that if this house
approves the deeply flawed withdrawal
agreement we risk being trapped in the
backstop inevitably come a right on will
friend confirm the income tax was
introduced in 1799 as a temporary
measure to pay for the Napoleonic Wars
well I have to say to my honourable
friend that I'm I'm interested in the
historical in the historical links that
he that he draws on this on this matter
but I think in relation to the in
relation to the backstop it is as I say
this is an issue that I recognize that
he and others have concerns about and I
continue to work to provide the
assurances which I hope would be enable
my honorable friend to be able to accept
a deal and make sure that we leave the
European Union with a deal Emma Reynolds
several members of her cabinet this
weekend have said that if her deal is
voted down then it should be for
Parliament to decide what happens next
does she agree there is there is a
process which is set in the legislation
that if the deal is voted down then it
is for the government within a certain
period of time to bring forward its
proposals to the to Parliament that a
motion will be put before Parliament and
following an amendment that was tabled
and agreed by Parliament a couple of
weeks ago that motion would be amendable
dr. Phillip Lee mr. speaker
judging by the tone and content of
today's statement it would appear that
the Prime Minister is still implacably
opposed to what I think is the only
democratic solution to this impasse for
the sake of clarity could she confirm
that she is so opposed that she would
prefer a No Deal what I what I want to
see happening and what I prefer is for
us to leave the European Union on the
basis of a deal on the basis of a good
deal and I believe this is a good deal
don't break both the Prime Minister and
the leader of the Opposition no there's
no point in kicking this can down the
road nothing is going to happen over
Christmas in the new year
can I ask the prime minister to bring
forward her a meaningful vote this week
and they asked the lead of the
opposition to bring forward his motion
of no-confidence this week and then this
week we can move on to where we know we
are going and that is a people's vote
can I say to the right honourable
gentleman now though there are further
discussions continuing the EU and those
will continue into the new year I thank
you mr. speaker and I wanted to commend
the Prime Minister's dogged
determination and so many people on the
streets of Taunton Dean this weekend
commended the Prime Minister for
attitude and wouldn't she agree with me
that given that this is the only deal on
the table everything must be done to
make it acceptable which means everybody
pulling together for the sake of the
nation but particularly for the sake of
our younger generations which don't seem
to be mentioned enough
this was reiterated to me at the
University Center of Somerset just this
weekend because we do have to leave them
with an economy that is fully
functioning and viable my own roofing is
absolutely right that we do need to
ensure that we're protecting the economy
for the future and that is what this
deal does and I think the young people
that she's referred to at that
University Center in Somerset would want
to see an not just a government but also
an opposition that is putting their
interests in the national interest first
rather than the opposition putting its
party interests first the last few weeks
of short this deal is for Norway today's
statement doesn't change that does the
Prime Minister now regret not working
cross-party to build consensus in this
house exam and why will she not accept
there is a way out of this hopeless
situation by extending article 50
working together without the political
posturing for a deal that works for
everyone this is about we have
negotiated a deal that works for
everyone I would simply say to be
honourable I say to the Honourable
ladies simply simply this in June 2016 a
vote was held and people voted to leave
the European Union in March 2019 29th of
March the date set for us to leave the
EU it would be nearly three years since
that vote I think people want us to get
on with leaving the European Union and
that's what we'll do Rachel McLane does
the Prime Minister realise that when
John Claude Janka called her nebulous he
fundamentally underestimated the
attitude of the British people who
that's what I found in my constituency
of radish this weekend mr. speaker where
what people are praised is the Prime
Minister's determination to get a deal
that works for mine constituency
can she display that similar
determination in ruling out second
referendum which I've been so insulting
to my constituents and suggest that they
don't know what they voted for the first
time out well I think my humble friend
makes a very important point that those
who many of those who advocate a second
referendum are many people who voted to
leave in the first in the referendum in
2016 would say exactly that they knew
what they were voting for they voted for
what they believed was right for this
country and actually they want to
government the deliver SOT so Wilson mr.
Speaker I must the Prime Minister before
a third day was better than the one but
we have now - which she can't give a
straight answer because I think she
knows the answer is nor what undermines
the integrity of our democracy Prime
Minister just to ask eventually members
of this house - knowingly vote for
something that will make that constant
you in spirit not those in this house
they want the people to have the final
say and whether they actually want that
to happen in the first place Prime
Minister is your deal better than the
one we have now
then if it is can we have the vote on
the meaningful vote this week I've set
out when the meaningful vote will take
place the honourable gentleman again
referenced people being poorer under
this deal than they are today they are
not going to be poorer under this deal
they are today that is that is the
economic analysis is very clear about
this and the economic analysis is clear
but the best deal the best approach in
turn that delivers on the referendum and
protects jobs in the economy is the deal
James cleverly Thank You mr. speaker
members a number of members opposite
need some on this side of the house have
been talking about people who have
changed their mind and how much it's
important that we respect people's
opportunity to change their mind would
she agree with me that whilst there is
no evidence that a meaningful number of
people have changed their mind with
respect to the referendum result it is
very clear a number of members opposite
have changed their mind because
previously they said they were going to
respect the outcome of the referendum
right they clearly now no longer wish to
do so and if they want to stop grexit
they should be honest with this house
and their constituents and just say so
Hey
I say to my honourable friend I
absolutely agree with him and it is the
case that both the Conservative Party
and the Labour Party campaigned in last
year's election on the basis that we
would respect the referendum and deliver
on the referendum result I believe
that's important I believe that that
should be the position that is being
taken by the opposition as well to
reflect their manifesto and to reflect
the promise that they gave to the
British people dr. Lisa Cameron
Conservatives have had the opportunity
to decide twice in the past two years on
the Prime Minister's own position in
what way is it's undemocratic to give
the people a second for exit well can I
say to the Honourable lady that the
first of all I think it is important
that we recognize when we have a
referendum in this country that we not
don't say to people this is a sort of
well if it comes out with the result
most people in Parliament want then
we'll accept it and if not we won't
actually we accept the results of
referendums in this country and I
believe a given that the majority of
members of this house stood last year on
a manifestos to respect the result of
that referendum we should do that Chris
bimmel and see a World Trade
Organisation terms from the 29th of
March not even including the opportunity
for tariff free trade under article 24
of the GATT and the immediate
opportunity to negotiate and conclude
free-trade agreements with both the EU
and the rest of the world hardly sounds
like an outcome to be avoided at all
costs and certainly not a disaster the
extent of any disruption of the move to
the WGA terms depends on the policies of
our European Union partners if it
becomes clear on Wednesday their
preparations appear to make transition
more difficult not easier will she
therefore make sure that the 39 billion
pounds we would otherwise pay to the EU
the first charge is on British
businesses affected by their policies
and will
she showed the first flash of steel by
making clear she is going to at least
consider the 1.2 billion pounds of sunk
costs in the Galileo project might come
into that consideration I say to my
rational friend that in the financial
settlement the work on the financial
settlements that took place that has led
to the thirty nine billion thirty four
to thirty nine billion which is
significantly less than the 100 billion
that was being talked about at the
European Union level at one stage did of
course take into account the all the
aspects of the United Kingdom's
contributions that have been made into
the European Union over over the number
of years of our of our membership and it
is as a result of the tough negotiations
that the UK undertook that we have seen
that some of money being significantly
less than the one that the European
Union initially thought of Catherine
Makino
on Friday I visited the Newcastle West
End food bank to drop off a Christmas
donation there now distributing about
eleven tons of food a month to people in
crisis half of whom are children her own
government's analysis shows that we will
be worse off under every brexit scenario
but particularly if we leave without an
agreement her No Deal threat makes no
sense she won't give the details she
won't give the economic analysis of the
costs so will she just take that threat
off the table and get give the
reassurance that this government her
government will not let the poorest in
society pay for this brexit impacts
the Honourable lady when looking at the
negotiations of this deal we wanted to
ensure that we could protect jobs and
that we would protect our prosperity of
the future and that's exactly what we
have done but I repeat what I have said
to other honourable members it's not
possible simply to wish away and no deal
without having an alternative to no deal
and that means either either having a
deal or not having brexit at all and I
believe that delivering on brexit is
what we should be doing and what this
house should be agreed is the government
to get off its knees in these
negotiations and can I will the Prime
Minister remind the EU this house and
perhaps even the cabinet that we are the
United Kingdom and that we are we are
perfectly capable of standing alone we
are not some kind of small third-world
backwater that is dependent on the
benevolence of the European Union the
way that the EU have treated her in
these negotiations is embarrassing for
the Prime Minister and humiliating for
the United Kingdom can I tell her that
if she were to go along to the EU now
and tell them in the face of their
intransigence she told them to get
stopped the huge proportion of the
British people would be absolutely right
behind her in this great battle between
Parliament and the people it's
absolutely critical that the Prime
Minister is on the side of the people
can I say to my honourable friend but I
believe that being on the side of the
people is about ensuring that this
government delivers on brexit and that's
what we'll do
no Lena Moran my Prime Minister David
Cameron has been taken on board to
backseat Drive this progress given that
original architecture Bannister I was
slightly concerned may I ask the Prime
Minister what exactly is the former
Prime Minister's role in this when
exactly was the last time she spoke to
him and one of my says he giving ya he's
not giving advice the last time I spoke
to him was when we actually agreed the
withdrawal agreement when I spoke to two
former Prime Minister's as a matter of
courtesy to indicate that too than what
had been negotiated with the European
Union mr. Robert Halfon Thank You mr.
Speaker I welcome the guarantees the
Prime Minister has given today about
having no second referendum of any kind
I also welcome her standing up to mr.
Juncker could I just say in plain words
up to the Prime Minister that if she
went to the European Union and said
young said you can stick the 39 billion
pounds of taxpayers money where the Sun
to Sun don't shine unless we get
movement and a legal movement on the
back stop she wouldn't be called
nebulous should be called the Iron Lady
I say to my little friend
I'd simply say to my honorable friend
that I think as I've said to other
members of this house it is important
for us to remember that actually there
would be whatever the circumstances
while leaving the European Union there
would be some financial obligations for
us and as a as a country that does meet
its legal obligations I think it would
be important for us to continue to do so
Chris Bryant the time in the world isn't
going to make the slightest difference
to the arithmetic in this house and the
truth is by delaying another 28 days
from today in holding the meaningful
vote the Prime Minister is playing into
the hands of the European Union she's
playing into the hands of those who want
to undermine our security she's playing
into the hands of those who want to be
our economic rivals and she's achieving
absolutely nothing for this country she
could invite every sin
remember the house ran to her gaff for
Christmas Day Boxing Day and New Year's
Eve and she's still going to lose the
vote so why doesn't she get on with it
this week I am seeking those further
assurances - from the European Union
I've listened to the house and that's
what I'm doing
did you gram
Mr Speaker I very much hope that the
Prime Minister can agree with the eeoa
legally-binding annex to the withdrawal
agreement on any intended use of the
backstop and I believe that could unite
many members of this house but given
that they too like us were elected on a
manifesto of respecting the referendum
result shouldn't any further
reassurances be the moment for labour
members to join with us in supporting a
practical compromise and ending
uncertainty okay I agree with my humble
friend that I think it is important that
when it comes to the vote but members
from across this whole house put the
interests of this country first put the
interests of delivering on the
referendum and doing it in a way that
does protect jobs and our security which
is exactly what I believe this deal does
Jim Shannon Minister the some of your
junior administer it lose in the payroll
I've told other MPs that the backstop
cannot be change because of the if it
wasn't it changed Leo Apotheker would
lose the Republic of Ireland election we
do need to have good relations with the
Republic of Ireland but Prime Minister
you are the prime minister I know your
responsibility is for the United Kingdom
of Great Britain and Northern Ireland
so can the Prime Minister remained the
members of her payroll team that
northern art is part of the United
Kingdom and that there's no onus on any
member or junior minister who could be a
cheerleader for the tea shop yeah can I
say to my honourable friend that the
reason the reasons why we have
negotiated what we have and the reasons
why we as a government we are committed
to Northern Ireland and to not having a
hard border between Northern Ireland and
Ireland
that's nothing to do with the views of
the tea shock it's nothing to do with
the views of the government of the
Republic of Ireland it's about the
commitment that we believe we should be
giving to the people of Northern Ireland
dr. Andrew Morrison the UK sensibly and
pragmatically continues to apply the
union customs code after praxis and
given from the beginning of the new year
the new UK customs declaration system
and the REC system that will replace
certificates of origin is it not the
case that the European Union would not
be acting in good faith if it insisted
on its backstop potentially out to 20
1999 as as cited in the withdrawal
agreement very clear with my honourable
friend that the backstop is as we have
said in the withdrawal agreement and has
been further confirmed by the council
conclusions last week is intended to be
temporary because article 50 does not
allow for a permanent arrangement to be
put in place but it is the case of
course that the existence of alternative
arrangements which would enable us to
deal with the issue of providing that
there is no hard border between North
Island and Ireland would it ensure that
the backstop need not be used and if it
was used that it could be replaced and
could be replaced quickly by those
rearrangements that's reversed mr. heft
my constituent who is currently
stockpiling insulin and does she believe
that urgent measures need to be put in
place for these vital sorts of
provisions the Department of the
Department of Health of course them are
putting arrangements in place making
contingency arrangements for no deal
that is part of the preparations that
are taking place which it is entirely
right for the government to do Alberta
Custer
securing the rights of British nationals
living in the eu-27 and the rights of EU
nationals here in the United Kingdom is
a matter of the utmost importance for
every member of this house in the
absence of any other alternative legal
document will the Prime Minister conform
only hard deal
absolutely guarantees in law the rights
of our fellow Brits in the EU and EU
nationals here yes I'm very happy to
give that confirmation to my honourable
friend and he's right to raise this as
an issue it was an issue at the early
early stage of negotiations where many
members of this house raised the
question of citizens rights now what we
hear is a lot about the backstop but
people of course are missing to mention
that that crucial issue of citizens
rights is reflected in and is protected
and the guarantees are given in the
withdrawal agreement Seema Malhotra mr.
speaker the Prime Minister continued to
put on this pretence there's some how
when the people voted they only gave
permission for her deal or for No Deal
she knows that when we leave the
European Union if we leave with no deal
we will lose access to 40-plus
international trade agreements covering
trade with 70 countries to EU criminal
databases to the EU single market which
over 70% of UK's exporting businesses
trade with and indeed there could be a
delay to new medicines reaching patients
in the UK of two to three years she
knows that there are other legal and
political options so isn't it time for
her to give herself a much better
Christmas to have a vote in the House
this week on her deal and then allow
Parliament to start to work together on
how we move forward I say to the
Honourable lady that it was the vote
that took place in 2016 that determined
that we should be leaving the European
Union I believe we should be leaving the
European Union with a good deal this is
a good deal I believe that alternatives
that have been put other alternatives
that have been put forward in some cases
don't deliver on the vote of the
referendum and in other cases maker
backs the use of a backstop even more
likely
give him faster but mr. speaker the
Prime Minister recall last week my
question was around how we ensure that
the backstop is clear cannot be foresee
you care can be kept in indefinitely due
to vetoes and extraneous issues what
comfort did you take from some of the
comments of other European is for
example the Chancellor of Austria and
the prime minister of Denmark this might
actually something that we can secure as
you cos United Kingdom is absolutely
right I think crucially a number of
European Union leaders made very clear
their view in relation to backstop being
temporary or not being used at all and
they did make clear that they were
willing to listen to further proposals
in order to give greater clarification
to that point that's exactly why I think
it's right that we carry on talking to
the European Union on this matter this
is Marian Fellowes
[Music]
so women's empowerment here in
Parliament why doesn't the Prime
Minister in power and peace here before
Christmas and why won't she empower the
people with her second people sport yeah
safely honourable lady I refer her to
the answers I've given to those
questions earlier president Yonkers not
ruffling the hair of female colleagues I
think the promise had got away lightly
there and we know that he follows what's
said in this house very carefully he
will have heard her today saying no
revocation of article 50 and no second
referendum and I suspect he does get
some succor from some of the things that
are said in this chamber can she now
States for president Janka the exact
date when the United Kingdom will be
leaving the European Union legislation
it's the 29th of March 2019
dr. Roopa speaker the Prime Minister's
not interested in the will of the people
apart from one day in 2016 and with her
minority government being the first ever
to be found in content and by pulling
the plug on the meaningful vote at the
last minute last week she's little
regard for the sovereignty of Parliament
either given that she's returned from
her latest travels empty-handed
due to her over headlines why won't she
allow MPs a vote on her deal this week
and consider extending article 50 it is
the season of miracles and goodwill but
no one no more let's all believe this is
all going to be neatly concluded by the
end of March I've answered those
questions previously as I've just said
to my honourable friend
the member for Torquay I think it is
important that we follow up on the
opportunity to see these further
political and legal assurances in
relation to the concern that people have
on the back stop and also as I indicated
also to my honourable friend the member
for South West Cambridgeshire that it is
important that we look at the status of
the political declaration which is
another issue which people have raised
speaker can I thank the Prime Minister
for reminding this house that 472
members sitting now actually cited to
give a people's vote in 2015 because I
suspect but if they had decided to keep
the vote just to themselves that they
would have voted overwhelming to remain
in the European Parliament which means
that now there's inbuilt bias against
delivering brexit so please steer course
straights Prime Minister the country
expects us to deliver brexit a people's
vote is simply an opportunity to try and
overturn the Democratic vote well my
honourable friend is absolutely right
and that's exactly what this government
is doing steering a course to deliver on
what people voted for we gave them the
decision we asked them to make that
decision they made that decision and we
should respect it plan B are no deals
yes what I'm working on at moment is to
ensure that we can get the assurances
necessary to deal with the concerns
people have on the deal that has been
negotiated
Mr Speaker I like to think of myself as
a friendly fellow and I have no
particular inclination to fall out with
colleagues on either side of the chamber
based on the details of the brexit deal
the one thing I've learned in politics
mr. speaker is it's perfectly reasonable
to look at identical information and
come to completely different conclusions
but on values that's where I disagree
and does the Prime Minister agree that
to have a second referendum would fund
early fundamentally undermine the
principle of democracy
I I believe though there are many people
who voted if not for the first time at
all certainly for the first time for
some considerable number of years in
that referendum they did so in the
belief that the politicians were going
to listen to them and I think their
belief and their faith in politics and
politicians and our democracy would be
shattered if they were asked to think
again we should deliver on the vote that
took place I gave mr. speaker I listened
very carefully to the words the Prime
Minister used when asked about
indicative votes in this house she said
we have no plans when asked whether she
would revoke article 50 she said this
government will not do if this house
voted to instruct the government to
revoke article 50 would she resign and
make way for another government that
will carry out the wishes of this house
if the honorable gentleman if this house
voted to revoke article 50 it will be
going against the wishes of the people
in the referendum in 2016
Matt woman speaking more than three
quarters of my constituents voted to
leave the European Union can the Prime
Minister imagine anything more
patronizing than the idea that they need
more democracy to another girl and does
she agree with me that their instruction
was very clearly that we should be
getting on with it I absolutely agree
with my honourable friend his
constituents thought when they voted
that the government were going to
deliver on their vote and that's exactly
what we should do would be divisive it
is not referenda per se that are
divisive in fact the 2016 referendum
would not have been divisive if the
promises made were deliverable the the
division in our country today only come
from two and a half years of practice
phantasms now hitting the wall of bricks
of reality Breck Satya see the Prime
Minister's deal is a betrayal and remain
as a furious because the whole brexit
argument was based on lies does the
Prime Minister agree that in our
democracy we should never be afraid of a
public vote but we should always oppose
fantasies and false promises making sure
the Honourable lady no member of this
house is afraid of a public vote members
of this house put themselves up for
public vote some on a number of
occasions in order to be elected into
this house but I also say to the
Honourable lady arguments were put there
were two sides of the argument at the in
the referendum there were people people
who people voted people voted on their
belief as to whether or not we should
stay in the European Union and I believe
that we should deliver on the vote that
people gave
Richard drafts you mr. speaker many here
including one or two senior members of
the cabinet now refer to the will of MPs
which is nothing more than a fig leaf to
remain can I ask my right on the friend
that it was the will of the majority of
MPs in this place to give the people a
vote they did so now we must honor it
and if we fall back on WTO terms so--but
leaders prime minister get this country
free its end this rancor my honourable
friend is absolutely right that it was
the will of MPs in this house that the
decision as to whether to stay in the
European Union be given to the people of
this country we did that and they voted
to leave and we should do it the house
may be interested to know that Larry the
cat's at number 10 just tweeted brexit
he said brexit updates giving people a
vote equals breaking faith does the
Prime Minister agree I think I've made I
think I've made a point clearly
throughout this afternoon but I believe
we should keep faith with the people by
delivering on the vote that they gave in
2016 will quints cube Mr Speaker I
wanted to support this deal I want to
support this deal I thank the prime
minister sincerely for listening to
concerns in particular around the
backstop does my right or a friend agree
with me that it is absolutely essential
that we give her the time necessary to
secure the concessions that this house
wants to see because I guarantee the
Prime Minister if she secures them I
will stand Foursquare behind her
thank my honourable friend and I thank
him for pointing out that actually
having listened to the house it's right
that I'm able to have that time to argue
that case with the European Union and
seek those further assurances that would
give the confidence not only to my own
offend but to all the members of this
house the damage being caused to
manufacturing particularly automotive by
her failure to rule like No Deal yes the
manufacturing industry was welcome to
the fact that we heard negotiate a deal
welcomed the trade arrangements that we
would negotiated in the future
partnership and I want to be able to
deliver on that for them yeah Smith mr.
speaker ahead of the 2016 hue membership
referendum the government spent over
nine million pounds of taxpayers money
on a leaflet delivered to every UK home
advocating that we remain but also
crucially saying that whatever the
outcome of that referendum that that
would be enacted last year 589 now
elected honorable and right honourable
members of this house stood on an
election manifesto pledges to deliver
that referendum results will my right
honourable friend confirm to this house
that we will be leaving the European
Union on the 29th of March next year
Deal or No Deal I'm happy to confirm
that we will be leaving the European
Union on the 29th of March next year and
I'm grateful to my own boyfriend for
having pointed out the significant
number of members of this house who
stood on that manifesto commitment to
deliver on that vote that people took in
2016 Stephen Kiner
I minister repeatedly claims that the
Norway plus option would require a
backstop but on the 3rd of December her
Attorney General told me from that
dispatch box that he could see no reason
why Norway plus would not satisfy the
stated objectives of the backstop could
she please confirm that she agrees with
her Attorney General on that point
one of our friends that the the issue is
whether or not you have the customs
union with partly about whether or not
you have the customs union within the
Norway plus model but the point is that
any the point about the backstop is it
is there to deal with the period from
the end of a transition period into the
new relationship the new relationship
being one that will deal with the
guarantee to the people of Northern
Ireland that there will be no hard
border in any alternative arrangement it
would be necessary to have that
negotiation norway plus is not something
that can just happen or we this house
might want to say it happens actually
norway plus would require that
negotiation and therefore because we
would have to negotiate to be a member
of after first in order to get that
arrangement in place and in doing that
therefore there would be a risk that
there will be a period of time when no
arrangement was in place and that would
require a backstop because it was
growing concern among my constituents of
the prospect to the second vote a deep
growing anger they feel that their vote
has beat stolen from them bearing in
mind that bearing in mind that they
advocate bearing in mind the advocates
of a second vote talked about chaos
confusion of uncertainty would my right
honourable friend agree with me that
that would be the result of a second
vote on the small eternally with my
honourable friend that i think there is
concern i think there should be
concerned about
the divisive nature of a second
referendum if that were to take place
and also concern that as he has said
from his constituents and from many
other people up and down the country
they trusted that the politicians were
going to deliver on their vote that they
gave in 2016 and we have a duty to do so
journey baby
it is clear the prime minister has
refused to rule out of no deal she's
refused to extend article 50 and she's
refused to allow the option of a
people's vote can she now tell the house
her plan if her deal does not make it
through a parliament
honorable lady that as I've said to a
number of other honourable members if
she and others want to ensure that there
is not a No Deal situation then they
have to either accept that the
alternatives are accepting a deal or no
brexit I believe we should be delivering
on brexit and I believe we should be
doing it with a good deal for the UK
Peter grant
Thank You mr. speaker can agenda means
it may Minister but it's not will name
Peas in this place you have manifest his
commitments to honor the Scottish
government has manifested commitments to
honor but early undemocratic for anyone
too tired to stand and there we could be
feminists to tell us how many people in
this place stood on a manifesto that
supported the chaos of a new deal and
given that the answer is London surely
that should be the first option that is
taken off the table and then we can talk
about what kind of deal they can get and
if we can't get a decent deal then not
leaving should be put back on the table
surely giving most choices to the people
is more democratic than forcing them out
on an audio loop exit that nobody voted
for of course we can ensure that we
don't leave with no deal we can do that
by ensuring that we leave with a deal
and a good deal for the whole of the
United Kingdom James was on a feat we
are now convinced that the Prime
Minister still agrees with the south but
is listening to very few other people
last week no less a person than her
predecessor Sir John Major called for an
extension of article 50 but stubbornly
she still refuses to listen to any
advice on this please will the Prime
Minister listen for once
I have been listening that's exactly why
I'm discussing with the we're having
further discussions with the European
Union in relation to the issue of the
backstop to seek the assurances that
members of this house want Liam Byrne
I'm Minister has said today that she's
determined to frustrate another voters
and people and she's done her level best
of a straight a vote in this Parliament
don't you understand why so many people
in here think that she is trying to
confront this house and bully this house
with a large minute choice between her
Deal and No Deal even when she knows the
catastrophic cost of No Deal dissuades
about industry so can I ask the Prime
Minister to clarify for the house this
afternoon
a simple fact it comes to a meaningful
votes in January this house will indeed
be able to rule out No Deal and if
necessary extend the motion that comes
before the house will of course be
amendable when it comes before the house
in in January but I have to say to the
honourable gentleness is about ensuring
that we can get the assurances from the
European Union that's what we're working
on that we bring back to this house
having listened to the concerns that
have been raised by members of this
house Alison Hewlett thank you very much
mr. speaker the premaster nur statement
says that she is working on the the
tackling the spread of deliberate
large-scale and systematic dissing the
include aim the disinformation of what
leave and things printed in the side of
buses the lady a number of things were
said on both sides of the campaign's
during the referendum on the European
Union I think the task that we have
before us now is not try to relive that
referendum but actually just get on with
the job of delivering on it
name's Bree talking to both sides in my
constituency on Saturday they're
wondering why since the PM knows about
our own brexit supporting MP's change of
heart in her why she won't now ask berry
for their conclusion on her botched deal
so I asked the prime minister does she
regret spending so long appeasing the
19:22 instead of building a deal that
works for the 48 and the 52 I think I'm
writing in the referendum his
constituency actually voted to leave the
European Union I think those people who
voted to leave will want the government
to deliver on that Thank You mr. speaker
mr. speaker no my my acoustics was he
voted the way they did and it was 58 to
42 but they're banned Europe for the
mishaps about what we were we lost our
jobs in manufacturing as a result of
going to finance it away from
manufacturing 34 of the 43 local
authorities are still 13 percent behind
wages from 2010 still not recovered
that's why revolted they've seen what's
been said they've listened to what has
been said but you're not giving them to
chance to vote on this offer not your
the view is terrible it is not typical
day we will be worse off and so it's a
no - you gave us a choice we should have
a choice to vote in this house today on
your knocker
I haven't made any offer well that's a
bit of a debate but not a matter for me
but the Prime Minister can defend her
own offer and I'm sure she will
the Prime Minister Thank You mr. speaker
can I say to the Honourable lady that of
course this house will have a choice it
will have a choice when the meaningful
vote is brought forward to be able to
look at whether or not it accepts the
deal that is on the table and and what
it wants in terms of the year of the
future that choice will be available
just as the choice was available to her
constituents and others mine and others
up and down the country in 2016 to
decide whether I'll stay in the EU Jack
Jamie mr. speaker 62 members from four
parties across this house of today
written to the Prime Minister
on the mounting concerns being expressed
in our great manufacturing industries
automotive aerospace shipbuilding state
bus building the food industry the Prime
Minister we are walking towards a cliff
we're walking towards a cliff and if
this uncertainty continues what are our
already bad decisions being made for
Britain will continue and dramatically
so in the first quarter of next year we
have to have a degree of certainty
without which the future for many
companies and workers would be
catastrophic
why does the Prime Minister not rule out
now any question of a No Deal bristles
we have of course been engaging with
manufacturing industry including the
automotive industry which is very
important to to this country and to jobs
in this in this country they
manufacturing industry supported and
welcomed the deal when the deal was
negotiated and I say to the honourable
gentleman that he wants to support
manufacturing industry wants to ensure
that they have that certainty in the
future then he can support the deal
we're streeting speaker the Prime
Minister has pointedly not said that her
deal is better than the one we already
have
what sort of Prime Minister puts a deal
to Parliament knowing it would make our
country worse off than it would
otherwise have been and what sort of
Prime Minister could possibly
countenance the reckless chaos of a No
Deal threats it isn't that an insult to
the office of Prime Minister gentlemen
can I say to the Honourable gentleman
his question appeared to be based on the
premise that it was possible that we
should be looking at staying with inside
the European Union the people voted for
us to leave the European Union what the
economic analysis shows is that the best
option in leaving the European Union
that meets that requirement and protects
jobs is the deal Tricia Gibson of the
opposition the Prime Minister has set
herself
firmly against putting this issue back
to the people clearly because she feels
as does the leader of the Opposition
that the result this time will be
different and does she agree with me
that for for both pact for both of the
main parties in this house we have come
full circle thing we have ended where we
have began and that is running scared of
you Kip to the honourable lady she she
suggested that I thought we shouldn't
have a second referendum because I
thought it might come out with a
different result actually no I don't
think it would come out with a different
result but but I just believe that when
we said to people in 2016 here is the
choice if we give you that choice and we
will abide by that choice we should
stick by our word
slaughter the height of irresponsibility
for the Prime Minister pretend she can
win a vote on her deal when every member
of this house
including her knows that she can't nor
if they're a majority for No Deal so
when they are both voted down
what next that question is fundamentally
important for the future of this country
and she can't or won't answer it she
shouldn't be in office it's the old
gentle as we continue to work on the
further assurances in relation to the
deal he knows full well the vote will
come before the house the house will
have its vote and thereafter if the deal
is not supported then the government
will bring forward its proposals for the
future steps that we were taking with
George the prime minister claims to know
what Lee voters voted for in 2016 but
when I've surveyed thousands of my
constituents
over half of leave voters said that they
wanted to stay in the single market
almost that many said they wanted to be
in the customs union and now that
they've seen the shape of the deal on
the table
these are leave voters 16 percent said
they've changed their mind and wanted to
remain in the European Union so how can
the Prime Minister not listen to voters
I hope that she will spend the time over
the next few weeks actually listening to
voters who voted and not to her own
rebellious backbenchers ad that I do
listen to to voters I speak to voters
and I talk to them and the overwhelming
view that is given to me by voters it's
they actually want to ensure that we get
on with delivering on the vote in 2016
[Applause]
[Music]
Diana Johnson any scenario whereby it
would be in the national interest to
extend article 50 can I say to the
humble they have answered the question
on extending article 50 I believe it is
important for us to deliver on the vote
that people took we have it in our
legislation that we will leave the
European Union on the 29th of March 2019
Martin Whitfield who's the prime
minister think will be held responsible
if there's a no deal the executive
Parliament's or the people who voted in
2016 members of members of this house
will have a decision to take in relation
to the in relation to the deal and
whether they want to leave the European
Union with a deal Rachel Maskull it is
economically corrosive delaying this
deal for each day that passes our
economy is sliding down and people are
becoming poorer businesses are losing
confidence in the light of the political
arithmetic meaning that this deal will
fall what discussions did the Prime
Minister have with her European cartman
counterparts this weekend about
alternatives including the extension of
article 50 the Honourable lady if she is
concerned and wants to give certainty to
business then she has one step that she
could take which would help which would
do that which is to back the deal
dr. Philippa Whitford very much mr.
speaker in light of the impact of the
loss of EU citizens in the NHS a 90
percent drop in nurses coming here and a
trebling of the number of EU nurses
leaving the Prime Minister has saw in
recent months to make clear to EU
citizens they are welcome and they are
secure however in a response to the
member for Southwest assure she implied
that they would only be secure if her
deal passes can she clarify because she
has just scared over 3 million people -
the lady I know she has a very personal
interest in this issue the withdrawal
agreement sets out the agreement that
has been reached between the United
Kingdom of the European Union which is
in relation to EU citizens here in the
UK and UK citizens in the European Union
as a government we have been clear that
we will protect the interests of
European Union citizens here in the
United Kingdom if there is a if there is
a no deal situation but of course I
cannot at this stage guarantee what
would be the situation for UK citizens
in the rest of in the European Union 27
that is a matter for those kind of those
countries in the European Union to set
forward and there the reciprocal
arrangement that guarantees both sides
is what is in the withdrawal agreement
live a third two speakers it's the Prime
Minister's own red lines that has
brought us to this situation as she's
now about to squander billions of pounds
worth of taxpayers money on preparing
for no deal when she knows there is no
majority in this house for no deal so
that is completely unjustifiable now if
we need more time to negotiate extending
article 50 is the way forwards and she
is yet again put another red line and
stopping us taking a logical step have
given ourselves more time to sort out
this situation isn't that the right way
forwards
honorable gentlemen life I've responded
to a number of questions in relation to
this if this house of course will have a
decision to take as to whether to accept
that deal that is that is on the table
you know I'm not working to get those
further assurances as I've said but this
house will have a decision as to whether
to accept that deal and if that deal is
voted down then we will have to look at
the the government will have to come
forward with its proposals for the next
steps but he talks uses this phrase that
a lot of people use about red lines
actually what the government has been
doing is respecting the votes that
people were gave in 2016 on issues such
as bringing an end to free movement and
making sure that we leave the European
Union Stephens
can apply Minister publish how many
additional several service jobs would be
required either with hug Deal or No Deal
unsecured could we measure that against
a number of several service jobs I've
been cut since the EU referendum I'm
very happy to write to the honourable
gentleman with the figures for the
number of civil servants who have been
employed and four numbers who are
continuing to be employed in terms of
dealing with these this leaving of the
European Union because it's not of
course we are making contingency
arrangements for no deal but there also
a lot of arranged preparations are
taking place which have involved the
employment of more civil servants which
are actually about preparing for the
deal and I'm with more in this
embarrassing reckless brexit we find
ourselves perilously close to was begun
to quell opposition within the Tory
party putting party before country now
we have a prime minister putting her own
interests above both party and country
when more the Prime Minister agree that
with no majority for her deal no deal or
any other deal that the only democratic
way forward is to put this back to the
people for a people's vote
[Music]
the party in this house that is putting
party before country is the Labour Party
the front
who are putting the interests of trying
to bring about a general election before
the interests of actually getting a deal
that works for this country
deirdre Brock
only 8% of my constituents in Edmond
lawfully voted to remain and they're
extremely concerned about the prospect
of a No Deal
so I'll repeat the question my
honourable friend for Adrienne Schatz us
which the prime minister signally failed
to answer will she publish her no deal
planning we are making preparations for
no deal these preparations are being
stepped up we're continuing to step up
those preparations we've already
published a number of issues in relation
to No Deal planning through the
technical notices that have been issued
and we will be continuing to make sure
that the information that is provided
externally that is necessary is that
which it is necessary to ensure all the
people who prepared for the possibility
of a No Deal scenario nay take in and I
thank the Prime Minister for making it
very clear in her statement in her words
that no deal risks jobs services and
security and can I ask her to act as the
leader of this great country and rule
out No Deal now gentlemen the only way
to rule out No Deal is to ensure that
there is a deal of enables us
the European Union Wayne David the Prime
Minister has used a mantra ad nauseam
it's her Deal or No Deal she's almost
repeated again just now but she but she
must be aware of at the Economist
magazine amongst many many of us have
said but a No Deal breaks it wrecks the
economy
why is she prepared to wreck the economy
and will she justify about to British
people honourable gentlemen I believe
that the best route forward for the
United Kingdom is to leave the European
Union with a deal with a good deal I
believe this is a good deal and one of
the things that's not continued the
Prime Minister statement in from the
council conclusions is about future of
the single market and she should know
that leaving the single market rests
80,000 jobs in Scotland so if any idea
how many jobs would be lost in the
Queensland bills and uh still states s
loss really lifting remarkable gentlemen
will be aware that within the political
declaration it is clear that we will
have a more ambitious trading
relationship with the European Union
than any other third country we will
become a third country when we leave the
European Union we have negotiated that
deal that future trade relationship and
that political declaration is the
instructions to the negotiations for the
future we've negotiated that precisely
with a in our minds the need to ensure
that we protect jobs and that's what
that deal will do Karen buck speak about
three-quarters of a million jobs at risk
of a No Deal British quarters the UK
trade observatory 42,000 of them in my
own borough of cities of westminster
isn't it absolutely clear this is the
most disastrous outcome and that the
Prime Minister is playing Russian
roulette with people's jobs given one of
the very few options that can command a
majority in this house is a measure to
stop No Deal
isn't it the height of irresponsibility
to make us wait a month for a meaningful
vote which will certainly
lost and not to commit to taking
whatever action is necessary including
suspending article 50 to make sure we do
not drive the British economy off a
cliff the Honourable lady the the house
will have a decision to take and it is
in it will be in the hands of this house
as to whether or not it wishes to
support a deal you can't wish No Deal
away you can only insure if we're not
going to leave with no deal then we have
to have an arrangement we have to have a
deal with which to leave the European
Union mr. speaker the Prime Minister
talked about integrity in our statement
and talked about the millions who
trusted in democracy what does she say
to those same billion civ witness the
dark money scandal vote leave breaking
the law the cash for votes and the hurt
government gerrymandering the brexit
committees and a legitimate vote of the
Scottish Parliament village of
legitimate bill of the Scottish
Parliament being avoided getting royal
assent by her court action or her ruling
the vote on appeal
halfway through the debate where does
the integrity on those matters yeah
people deserve their say I say to the
the Honourable gentleman that I believe
it was the case that this issue of the
continuity bill in Scotland was to
discuss whilst this matter was discussed
with the government at the time the
government made clear its position in
relation to that continuity bill in
relation to the in relation to this
matter there were discussions with the
Scottish government throughout the
withdrawal Act going through the
withdrawal that going through this going
through this house and we have ensured
at every stage that we have been
consulting with engaging with the
Scottish government and indeed with the
Welsh Government on these matters
Matt Western speaker we have endured
months of obfuscation and prevarication
Fajr and more Fajr made in Maidenhead
the Prime Minister described perfect as
the enemy of the good but she will also
accept a good leadership demands the
demonstration of the courage of one's
convictions Prime Minister we are in a
serious crisis business demands action
urgently can I ask that it is totally
irresponsible and unacceptable to delay
the vote until we commencing the 7th or
14th of January we need a vote now and
if we do not have that vote before
Christmas please extend article 50
because businesses demand it what
businesses have been clear that they
want is that they want to see us leaving
with the deal they've welcomed the deal
that we've negotiated and is therefore
in members hands to recognize that when
they come to the vote the murders is she
saying beyond a shadow of a doubt in all
circumstances whatsoever that when her
deal is voted down she will not bring
forward any other option over them
leaving without a deal what I have been
clear about is the the decision that
members of this house will have to take
if the deal is voted down is very clear
we have the process set out in
legislation which the government will
follow
karamaneh hand over the weekends we
heard the news that many in the academic
community we're treating the immigration
rules for EU nationals would be based on
salary and perceived skill levels can
the plane minister please elaborate
elaborate on how categorization of skill
level will be done and can she explain
how we will continue to attract talented
young researchers who are in farm less
than 30 thousand pounds we've been clear
for some time now it wasn't at the
weekend that we said that we were going
to a skills-based immigration system
we've been clear for some months now
that we're going to a schools based
immigration system
these figure of 30,000 was the figure
that was set out in the map report Neil
Coyle
Thank You mr. speaker the premise
describes a new vote on Europe is
somehow an act of bad faith this is the
primaries who tried to deny Parliament a
meaningful vote at all then pulled the
vote when she knew she would lose this
is the Primus who claims it's her way or
no way
despite the option revoking article 50
and this is the Prime Minister who told
10,000 people from other EU countries
living working and contributing in my
constituency that they had somehow
jumped the queue is she in any position
at all to lecture anyone about what it
means to act in good faith on this issue
I repeat to the honourable gentleman the
points that I've made about the vote
that took place in 2016 about the duty
that we have in relation to that you
gave me what place is modern well what
place Brazzaville passive force for
parcel parcels in goods that move their
vote wife just told me the other worried
about this be exit deal also like it
says you see corporate cases in Bell
toll where unemployment is raising
workers are worried about the future
do you have a Christmas message for them
to play Minister or do you want an event
like to 2017 general election
the Honorable gentleman that I believe
that it is right for this country to
leave the European Union that's what
people voted for I believe it's right
for us to leave with a good deal I
believe we have a good deal Parliament
has expressed members of this house have
expressed some concerns about a
particular aspect of that and I am
working to reassure them on that
particular point and then I hope it will
be possible for members of this house to
recognize the importance of protecting
jobs and to support a good deal for
leaving the EU Daniel's Eichner Thank
You mr. speaker the 48% seem to count
for nothing anymore they did not vote
for this descent into chaos of many
cautions that you should not leave
unless you know where you are going so
is it not time in the national interest
to revoke article 50 not least to allow
those who claim to speak to the 52% to
sort out what they actually want
revoking article 50 means staying in the
European Union and it's not possible to
revoke article 50 to go back into the EU
and then come back out again in a few
months time the judgment of the European
Court of Justice was absolutely clear on
this point
revoking article 50 means staying in the
European Union margin de democracy is a
process not a historical event in time
and it is essential that the public
making faith in that process so can the
Prime Minister give me one good reason
why we should respect the result of a
referendum that was my affianced ensive
cheating Andrew breaking but having
another referendum
can I say to the honest German as a to
the honorable gentleman the the
referendum took place the government was
clear at the time a parliament was clear
at the time this was a choice for the
British people the British people chose
and I think we should deliver on that
choice yes the point of order mr. Jeremy
Corbyn speaker I've listened very
carefully to all of the answers the
prime minister gave during this lengthy
exchange today I've listened very
carefully to what members on all sides
of the house have said and it's very
clear that it is very bad unacceptable
that we should be waiting almost a month
before we have a meaningful vote on a
crucial issue facing the future of this
country
the Prime Minister has object Lee
refused to ensure there's a vote a vote
took place on the date she agreed she
refuses to allow a vote to take place
this week and is now I assume thinking
the vote will be on the 14th of January
almost a month away
this is unacceptable in any way
whatsoever so mr. speaker is the only
way I can think of of ensuring a vote
takes place this week I'm about to table
a motion which says the following that
this house has no confidence in the
Prime Minister do
due to her failure to allow the House of
Commons have a meaningful vote straight
away on the withdrawal agreement and
framework for future relationships
between the UK and the European Union
and that will be tabled immediately mr.
speaker thank you said it requires no
response from me but it's on the record
and I move to the next a point of order
which is from the Honourable and Leonard
lady point of order Joanna Chetty - a
couple of questions from my honorable
friends the prime minister has implied
that Scottish National Party MPs and the
Scottish Government
we're aware at the time the bill was
brought that the UK withdrawal from the
EU veto continuity Scotland bill was out
with the legislative competence of the
Scottish Parliament
I'm sure the Prime Minister has
inadvertently overlooked the fact that
last week the UK Supreme Court passed
judgment in the case the Attorney
General's reference about this case and
found an actual fact that the bill was
within the confidence of the vast
allsafe one section section 17 and that
it was only the subsequent enactment of
the EU withdrawal Act which
retrospectively took pers away from the
Scottish Parliament to me that the bill
was no longer within its powers
Mr Speaker touring members of the
Scottish Parliament have been peddling
misinformation about the Supreme Court
judgments and have been a number of
inaccurate media reports over the last
few days I am certain that the prime
minister would not mean to perpetuate
misunderstandings about a judgment of
the United Kingdom Supreme Court and I
seek your guidance and how I can put the
matter Street and on the record in this
respect thank you well let me say to the
unrelated lady that I think that she has
found her own salvation she's aware of
the device one might almost
Kosovo's devoted a ruse of an attempted
but in practice bogus point of order to
get across a particular point which is
dear to her head and
and she succeeded in that mission with
admirable clarity and eloquence the
point is on the record and it will be
read in the official report and I
however have a sense that the honor
Allah no need lady will seek to spread
copies of the official report far and
wide in her own constituency and
doubtless beyond so far as ministers are
concerned including the Prime Minister
it is of course incumbent upon any
Minister who thinks he or she may
inadvertently have given incorrect
information to the house to correct the
record whether in this case it is
decided to do so is not a matter for me
but I hope that she feels that she has
have achieved her objective
thus afternoon point of order mr. Tom
break key mr. speaker mr. speaker over
the weekend it became very clear that
the Prime Minister has some strong views
on certain things one of them being Tony
Blair which I know she shares with the
leader of the Opposition and also the
merits of a people's vote against
something that she shares with the
leader of the Opposition however mr.
speaker however intense the Prime
Minister's antipathy towards a people's
vote is is it in order for her to leak
chunks of her speech in advance of her
coming here to the house to make the
statement which contains the same chunks
of her speech as was leaked to the press
at 10:30 last night well I think the
right honourable gentleman for giving me
notice that he wish to raise this matter
certainly I agree wholeheartedly and
without equivocation with the
proposition that announcements of
government policy should be made in this
house and should not be pre announced to
the media this is not just a courtesy
expected of the government but an
important principle I think it fair only
to add in response to the right
honourable gentleman however that the
government might in this case argue that
the number-10 press release to which the
right honourable gentleman referred
contain no announcement of government
policy it merely reiterated what the
Prime Minister told the house last week
I do understand the sense of disquiet
even irritation at the right
honorable gentleman feels but I think in
the name of even-handedness it is
reasonable for me to put that second
point on the record to sit alongside and
to be judged against the first yes of
course I will come to it I'm saving him
up I don't want to squander the
Honorable gentleman too early
point of order mr. Frank field given
your record mr. speaker as being a real
champion of backbenchers against both
front benches is there a way which those
of us who want to move to a vote on what
the options are opened to the country if
we don't support the government motion
which has been delayed by now a month
would have the opportunity of doing
expressing our views to see whether
there's agreement in the house where one
or more lines of attack before we rise
for Christmas I indicated last week that
there were two means by which the votes
could be deferred and without rehashing
all of that for the right honourable
gentleman or others he will recall that
I thought that there was a preferable
way to do it and a much less preferable
way to do it the government chose the
course that he did and as things stand
it's a course appears to be set I also
explained to the house and with a view
to people outside this house that
whatever the chair might think about
matters of procedure the chair must
operate within the powers of the chair
manifestly the chair cannot act ultra
varies the clear evidence is and the
precedents all support this that an
order of the day in respect of a piece
of government business can be moved only
by a representative of the government
that is to say a minister or a
government whip so I was able to express
some disquiet on behalf of many members
across the house at the sudden deferral
of the vote but I was not in a position
to bring about the continuation of the
debate or the vote upon it when the
right honourable gentleman asks what
recourse he has is there any recourse he
has I suppose what I would say to the
right honourable gentleman is that it's
always possible for members to table
motions in this house I'm not exhorting
him to do so and nor am i discouraging
him from do so doing so the read on
reserve was extremely experienced and he
knows that that option exists he has a
motion on the paper he can seek to
gather support for that motion or if
another motion that is judged to be
pertinent to his objectives is tabled he
can seek to garner support for such an
approach my role is to serve this house
I would be perfectly happy to chair
debates over the Christmas period I
would be perfectly happy to come back on
the 2nd of January and to sit in this
year millions of people are going to be
working on the 2nd of January we could
do that but it's not for me to say when
the house should sit when it should
debate and when it should vote that has
to be determined by others but I am here
to serve and if the house decided that
it wanted to proceed at a different rate
at a faster pace it would be my
responsibility to be here and I would
gladly accept that responsibility mr.
Frank further to that point of order mr.
speaker would you be in order if one or
more of the opposition parties gave
their time early in the new year so that
we could reassemble and vote on the six
or so options you might actually choose
would that be in order even if the
government hadn't moved their own
amendment my sense is that for the date
upon which the house sits to be changed
would very likely require a conversation
I am speaking I say to the right
honourable gentleman for the avoidance
of doubt off the top of my head it
almost certainly would require a
conversation and agreement between the
usual channels
and if the were such an agreement
nothing is impossible the right
honourable gentleman will know that
there is a supply of opposition days but
the government will normally give an
indication of when there will be an
opposition day and that is usually a
matter of negotiation between the two
sides it's not something on which the
speaker can rule but I don't say that
what he is suggesting is impossible and
what I am suggesting is that there seems
to be some distance to travel between
his aspiration and its realization a
point of order mr. Angus Brendon McNeil
further to the point of order by my
learned colleague from endless Southwest
about the response the prime minister
gave me to my question of the statement
and when the Prime Minister has been in
a vent over look at the facts of the
matter in the UK withdrawal from the EU
bill of the Scottish Parliament when
would a convention suggest in this house
that the Prime Minister be expected to
correct the record as a courtesy to the
House to be accurate given particularly
her office that she holds in the United
Kingdom if an error is judged to have
been made the correction should be made
with dispatch in other words if a member
if a member I say to the honourable
gentleman I believes that he or she has
earned there should not be delay the
record should be corrected without delay
I'm extremely grateful to colleagues if
there are no further points of order we
come now to the statement by the
secretary of state for business energy
and industrial strategy the ever-present
and unfailingly courteous secretary of
state dr. Greg Clark very much indeed
mr. speaker and with your permission I'd
like to make a statement on the good
work plan published today which sets out
the government's vision for the future
of the UK labour market and how we will
implement the recommendations that arise
from the Matthew Taylor review of modern
working